all right during the last total solar
eclipse to cross the United States in
1918 the University of Chicago sent an
expedition to Green River Wyoming back
then the city was in the path of
totality well today it's Jackson Wyoming
about 150 miles northwest of Green River
that's in the sweet spot and I'm jealous
cuz Jeff Glor is in Jackson outside the
Chapel of Transfiguration were the most
popular attractions inside Grand Teton
National Park Jeff good morning Nora
good morning to you Grand Teton is one
of 21 National Park properties in the
zone of totality but this is the most
high-profile by far and should offer the
best views today
campers started rolling in here last
week trying to claim the best spots and
Rangers were also busy this weekend
getting tips with telescopes and adding
to their staff by swearing in some
deputy Park Rangers that was pretty to
cool some kids getting sworn in a park
superintendent told us that today is
expected to be the busiest day in park
history and this park was established in
1929 about 20 miles south here the
Jackson Hole ski tram is taking 800
guests who paid 150 bucks a pop up to
the top of rendezvous peak for a
sky-high view of the Eclipse those
people will watch at 10,000 feet they're
also some people who actually camped out
at the top of Grand Teton as well to
watch the Eclipse and assuming we get
some morning clouds to burn off here the
view should be spectacular Dale Jeff I'm
telling you talk about spectacular you
look gorgeous today it looks like you're
in the middle of a painting honestly
really you look really great there's
there's there's not much better than
than Grand Teton National Park in
Wyoming in the summer no lucky you
thanks a lot